Hi, I get a lot of people asking me for
advice about how to work in AI safety
research. How do you get started in an
AI safety career? Rob, you should do a
video about AI safety research careers.
Oh, here comes one now. Rob, you should
do a video about AI safety research
careers. And my answer is generally the
same. Easy. There's a great careers
advice organization called 80,000 hours.
They've written a detailed guide about
it. You can also book one-on-one career
coaching calls with them for free. Link
in the description. But doctor, I am
careers advice organization 80,000
hours. Oh, you want me to make a video?
Can't people just read your career
guide? I don't know. People don't really
like to read, huh? Do you think maybe
people should learn to enjoy reading
before they try to embark on a highly
intellectual career path?
Can we just do the video? Yeah.
[Music]
If you watch this channel, then you know
that AI safety research is important. AI
is having increasingly large impacts on
the world. We don't really understand
what we're doing. And there remains a
distinct possibility that AI systems at
some point in the future totally
disempower humanity and maybe drive us
extinct in a way which probably destroys
almost all value in the universe. It's
not at all clear how likely that is, but
it's very obviously a lot more likely
than we would want it to be. It would be
nice to have some wellfounded technical
asurances that that kind of thing won't
happen. In the same way, you'd probably
want some reasonable assurances that a
plane won't crash before you load your
entire family into it. Getting that kind
of confidence in the safety of AI
systems is hard. Now, there's obviously
a lot of different things we could do to
improve our chances of survival,
including things like policy and
governance work. You know, trying to
figure out ways for our society to
coordinate to navigate this new
situation. Well, in the plain metaphor,
that's like trying to set up the FAA or
something. There's also advocacy and
communication, field building, ops,
organizing, all sorts of things. And
there are good career guides about those
things as well. Links in the
description. That's very important work.
But what we're focusing on in this video
is technical safety research. This is
like the engineers who designed the
airplane safety systems, the air traffic
control protocols, and so on. There's
not a clear boundary here. Governance
and policy work obviously needs
technical people as well. Pretty
urgently actually. But yeah, in this
video I'm specifically talking about
people who might be interested in doing
technical AI safety research. If that's
you, stick around. If that might be you,
but you're not sure, like, you know, is
this right for me? Am I good enough?
Then for sure stick around, cuz we'll
talk about that and you might be
surprised. And if that's not you, then
maybe stick around anyway, cuz this
script ended up a little spicier than my
usual. I don't know. I have some
opinions in this one. But yeah,
technical AI safety research. What does
that involve? What jobs are out there?
So, there's a lot of different types of
technical safety work. Some people are
trying to understand how trained neural
networks actually operate by taking them
apart and looking closely at their
internal mechanisms. Some people are
studying the dynamics of the training
process to design training processes
that are less likely to produce scheming
or misaligned models. Others are
designing post-training and fine-tuning
schemes like RLHF, reinforcement
learning from human feedback to try to
get current systems to be more likely to
do what we want. And other people are
designing ways to test and evaluate
those kinds of training schemes. Some
people are demonstrating the
circumstances under which current models
display behaviors that would be very
dangerous for more advanced systems to
do and others are designing monitoring
protocols to spot when that kind of
thing is happening and control protocols
that might allow us to get useful work
out of those kinds of systems anyway.
Some people are designing ways to
evaluate how capable current models are
at the dangerous capabilities we're
concerned about them eventually
developing. And other people are trying
to formally prove things about neural
networks. But that's probably
impossible. So they're trying to come up
with some kind of relaxed notion of a
proof that still lets us make meaningful
principled theoretical claims about the
behavior of these things. Whereas some
people are simply studying models the
same way a psychiatrist studies people,
just talking to them and seeing how they
react. For a while, people were trying
to resolve a load of fundamental
confusions that we almost certainly have
about what it means to be a thinking
agent that wants things and is
physically embedded in the world. We've
mostly given up on that because it's
hard and we've kind of run out of time.
So, we're mostly just going to have to
try to do our best while being kind of
confused. But, there is still work being
done on just trying to clarify things
and help us get less confused about this
mess and plus a ton of other stuff that
I haven't mentioned. It's a lot. There
are a few ways I might try to organize
it. One important axis along which it
varies goes from conceptual and
theoretical to practical and empirical.
This is kind of similar to applied and
theoretical physics. So, on one end of
the spectrum, you've got stuff which is
so theoretical and abstract that there's
no way to know if it'll even ever be
useful. all the way to the other end
where you've got stuff which is
basically just standard ML engineering
on current systems that people would
probably be doing anyway and which
doesn't deal with any of the things that
actually make the alignment problem hard
and everything in between. Theoretical
work has been somewhat neglected
recently in my opinion because we now
have all these cool models to play with
and it's easy to get legible results
that way. Whereas theoretical work
doesn't depend as much on any specific
model. It's mostly mathematics and
philosophy, which actually, can we take
a second to talk about what mathematics
and philosophy really are? Cuz I feel
like school doesn't do a great job of
getting that across. In my mind, the job
of philosophy is to tackle questions
that we don't know how to think about,
to grapple with the ineffable and see if
we might not be able to f it after all.
Point being, once you've done good
enough philosophy on a question, you've
figured out how to think about it
effectively. So, it stops being
philosophy. Like, the question of how
objects move around was once philosophy.
Aristotle had some ideas. They didn't
work very well. You had philosophers
dropping cannonballs off the leaning
tower of Pisa, that kind of thing. Not
physicists, not at the time,
philosophers. You know, Isaac Newton, we
think of him as a physicist, but he
thought of himself as a philosopher. He
took these philosophical questions about
motion and he thought about them clearly
enough that it became possible to do
mathematics to them. And that approach
turned out to be so effective that it
became its own field separate from
philosophy. And so when we learn about
Newton's work on motion, we learn about
it in physics classes, even though at
the time he was doing philosophy. So
what ends up being left in philosophy is
all of the things that we're still kind
of confused about. If you only think of
philosophy as that, you're kind of
leaving out the field's biggest
successes, which are most of the other
subjects you study at school, right?
Mathematics, the sciences, economics,
even history is largely applied
epistemology. So yeah, I think of the
job of philosophy as being to take
things that we don't know how to think
about and think about them until they
become something that isn't philosophy.
And there are clearly a lot of things in
advanced AI that we're not sure how to
think clearly about. So we need this
kind of work. Excuse me. Um why is there
a long digression on the nature of
mathematics and philosophy in the middle
of a career's advice video? I think it's
important and interesting. Anyway, it's
not like you're paying me. Okay. But so
mathematics, the thing they call
mathematics in school, that's mostly
just how to do calculations. It doesn't
really get to the core of what
mathematics is. In my opinion,
mathematics is the study of precisely
imagined things. It's about imagining
something so precisely that your
imagined version of it is actually fully
defined. There's no space for opinion or
interpretation. You know, two
mathematicians thinking about the same
mathematical object defined the same way
are not thinking about two different
versions of the same thing. They're
actually considering exactly the same
object, right? They don't call this an
empty set. That's the empty set. There's
only one. Now, precisely imagining
things and then reasoning about their
properties and behaviors turns out to be
an unreasonably effective way to think
about a lot of the world. Critically,
the fact that it lets you have multiple
people thinking about the same thing,
not subtly different things, allows you
to build and verify much longer chains
of reasoning than you could get away
with in any other paradigm. And that's
basically a necessity if you want to do
highly complex and impactful things. At
least if you want to do highly complex
and impactful things while having any
idea what the you're doing. And so often
theoretical alignment research involves
taking philosophical ideas about minds
and goals and agency and safety and
trying to pin them down, trying to
imagine them so precisely that they
become mathematics. And if they can't be
expressed well with our current
mathematics, then the task becomes one
of figuring out what new mathematics
needs to be invented and then inventing
it. Imagine you're starting from scratch
trying to safely fly a rocket to the
moon. What would it take for you to
realize that in order to understand
orbital maneuvering, you need something
like calculus and then go on to invent
calculus? That's the kind of thing
theoretical alignment research aspires
to be. It's not easy, but there has been
some interesting work done. Some of
which I've talked about on computer
file, some of which I've talked about on
this channel. You know, my videos on
eliciting latent knowledge or messa
optimization. This is uh fairly
theoretical work. At least it was at the
time before some of it started just
actually happening. We're getting less
theoretical by the day. But the theory
work is not done yet. So maybe give us a
hand. But the classic problem with
theoretical work is okay, you've
developed these beautiful mathematical
constructs and learned a lot about their
properties. Why do we believe that these
particular precisely imagined things
will importantly correspond to any
particular not imagined thing? Why this
mathematical construct instead of
another one? There's a lot of existing
evidence available in the world that you
can use to guide your theoretical work.
But you might want to do some
experiments to collect more evidence,
which is where empirical work comes in.
Day-to-day, the empirical work is mostly
ML engineering. It's figuring out how
current systems actually work under the
hood, conducting experiments to test
safety and alignment techniques, and so
on. For example, some safety problems
emerge from the opakqueness of current
AI techniques. You know, our cuttingedge
AI models are arguably the most complex
artifacts humanity has ever created, but
we kind of grew them rather than built
them. We don't really understand how
they do what they do. It's a lot like
the human brain in that way. So imagine
being a neuroscientist. Well, maybe you
are a neuroscientist, in which case you
shouldn't have to tax your imagination
too hard. Except imagine that instead of
brains being these fragile, precious,
delicate things where your access to
them is inconveniently blocked by
so-called ethics committees and skulls,
instead you have total freedom. You can
take them apart and poke and prod them
however you want. You can, with perfect
reproducibility, run whatever
experiments you like, taking whatever
measurements you want at any time during
any task, and the cops can't do a damn
thing about it. That's called
interpretability research and it's one
of the more popular types of empirical
work. We've talked about a lot of
empirical work on this channel. Things
like scalable oversight, grid worlds, uh
reward modeling, the control video, a
lot of other stuff that we haven't
covered as well. The trouble with the
more empirical stuff is that you can
only study systems that actually exist.
And there's a limit to what that can
tell you about the systems that will
exist in the future. For example, a lot
of the biggest problems with AI safety
only happen when the system has enough
situational awareness to understand its
training setup and enough strategic
reasoning ability to consider the
possibility of deception and so on. And
it's only recently that AI systems have
been anywhere close to that. So, it's
hard to empirically study that kind of
thing. But there's some interesting
engineering to be done in trying to
figure out ways to augment current
models to make them able to carry out
these dangerous behaviors in order to
study them. We talked about some of that
in the previous video. Of course, as
models get more powerful, the empirical
work gets more useful, but the less time
we have left to do
it. So, yeah, that's a little of what
technical safety research is about. What
do you think? Are you interested in
pushing the boundaries of humanity's
understanding of understanding itself,
our understanding of what it means to be
a thinking, deciding agent embodied in
the world? Are you interested in pinning
those things down fully, in transforming
them from philosophy into mathematics,
and then solving that mathematics? Are
you interested in probing the depths of
the most complex artifacts humanity has
ever created and understanding them so
profoundly that you can design systems
such that you can be confident ahead of
time that they'll behave in ways
beneficial to humanity? Are you
interested in thereby avoiding a global
catastrophe and ushering in a new age of
human flourishing that staggers the
imagination and makes the modern world
look
medieval? Ah, cool. Me too. But do you
have what it takes? First off, do you
have the skills? Now, what skills you
need depends somewhat on what role you
want to play. Do you want to be a
research lead or research scientist who
designs experiments and writes papers?
Or do you want to be a research engineer
or contributor who actually implements
and runs experiments and works on papers
without setting the research agenda?
This is kind of a spectrum as well. Lots
of people are doing some combination.
Either way, you'll need skills in
software engineering and probably ML
engineering. The empirical stuff needs
more software engineering. The
theoretical stuff needs more
mathematics.
You might want to get a PhD, but I would
generally recommend against it. Research
leads often have PhDs, but you don't
strictly need one, and engineers and
contributors generally don't have one. I
would say if you know that the research
you'll do for your PhD is actually the
research that you would want to be doing
anyway, then go for it. But if you're
treating a PhD as a stepping stone to
the work you really want to be doing,
then there are probably quicker and
mentally healthier ways to get there.
But if you're already about to complete
a doctorate in mathematics or computer
science, then cool. And actually, you
don't need to already be studying maths
or computer science. You could be doing
physics or other quantitative subjects
as varied as neuroscience or economics
can all work. The thing is a deep
learning is just not that deep actually.
You know, ML is a pretty new field. So,
compared to something like physics, it's
surprisingly easy to get to the
frontier. So, it's pretty common to come
into the field sideways as it were from
another field. A lot of people do this.
If you have expertise in something
scientific and mathematical, it
shouldn't take you too long to get good
enough at AI to make meaningful
contributions. How good do you have to
be? Well, it's hard to quantify this
kind of thing, but some of the companies
have put out exactly what they're
looking for. So, if you pass that bar,
you're definitely good enough. A hiring
manager at Anthropic said that if you
could, with a few weeks work, write a
new feature or fix a serious bug in a
major ML library, they'd want to
interview you straight away. And the
DeepMind team said, "If you can
reproduce a typical ML paper in a few
hundred hours and your interests align
with ours, we're probably interested in
interviewing you." That interests align
with ours part seems important for
safety roles. The good teams are
especially interested in people who are
up to date on the safety literature and
have their own thoughts about it as well
as being technically competent. Are you
that kind of person? Oh, you are. You're
already the kind of person who can
replicate ML papers for fun and you
already know a lot about AI safety. What
are you doing watching YouTube for? Go
apply for some positions. Link in the
description. Okay, that was like five
people. Realistically, I probably
already know four of you. Hi, Neil.
Thanks for watching my videos. Get back
to work. Okay, everyone else, the people
who aren't quite the kind of person who
could just jump into this work straight
away. Could you become that kind of
person? Could you imagine a rocky
training montage that could get you
there? Cuz if you feel like you might be
able to get there, it's probably worth
trying. So, how do you actually do the
training montage? Well, if you don't
have a solid background knowledge of
coding, maths, and deep learning, that's
where to start if you're starting from
scratch. There's a lot of great
resources to help with that. I'm not
going to talk through all of them, but
you can see the section of the career
guide for that. There's a link in the
description, and there's a bunch of
courses you can take as well. I'll talk
about those later. For empirical work,
you might want to practice doing ML
engineering by replicating existing
papers. Learn about safety and alignment
techniques by reproducing the results of
some safety papers. So, all of that
should help you get the skills you need.
But just having the skills isn't enough.
Good safety research also requires a
particular mindset which not everyone
has. First thing is are you able to take
this seriously. Now that doesn't mean
not making jokes. In fact, a sense of
humor is becoming increasingly
important. It means appreciating the
magnitude of what's at stake and the
level of the challenge facing us. Acting
with the gravitas appropriate for what
we're building. The future may be much
better or much worse than most people
are willing to seriously consider. Some
people claim to realize this, but many
of them don't seem to have really
internalized that this is not a game.
This is for keeps and it requires
serious thought. If your approach to the
future of humanity is mostly based on
vibes, I would advise you to experiment
with actual thinking. Takes a lot more
work, but it can be very rewarding. If
you're constitutionally opposed to
serious and careful thought, then well,
I mean, you can do what you like, I
guess. I just ask that you do it quietly
because grown-ups are talking. You also
need something that I might call
conceptual clarity or big picture
thinking. It's very easy to get sucked
into a mindset where someone has given
you a number that you're meant to make
go up and if number go up then good.
This is psychologically comfortable, but
that kind of thinking really won't cut
it if you want to do good safety
research because the actual number
you're trying to make go up is like the
overall expected goodness of humanity's
future or something like that, which
your manager is not going to tell you in
your performance reviews because one,
they aren't paid to care about how good
your work is for humanity's future, and
two, they don't know, and nor do you.
But you still need to make decisions
about your work in spite of the lack of
easy proxies for what matters. And that
means you need clear and accurate mental
models of the overall situation, not
just your own narrow part of it. And you
need to be able to think carefully and
decide what's best and not just run in
whatever hamster wheel you happen to
find yourself in. This is part of what
makes safety research so interesting.
You're not just making tweaks to make
the number go up. You have more
interesting and challenging things to
think about. And in fact, we may not
even have a working paradigm, right? Our
current approaches may be fundamentally
confused. So it's important to be able
to think big and try to deeply
understand the whole problem. But Rob,
that sounds hard. I'd actually prefer a
psychologically comfortable job. I like
making number go up. Okay, fair. And
good self-awareness. It is totally
possible to do good and useful work just
solving engineering problems for a good
safety team. But you have to pick the
right team because something that it's
vital to keep in mind over your career
is the fact that not everything labeled
as safety is any good. Some work that
calls itself safety is mainly about
making systems more capable in a way
that doesn't really make them any less
likely to cause catastrophes. Some work
that calls itself safety is kind of
thought of by upper management as
basically coming out of the marketing or
public relations budget. It's there to
make the company look good rather than
to really improve the safety of the
systems. If what you're asked to do is
stop language models from saying bad
words, it's possible that you're doing
fundamental science to learn important
things about the nature of alignment
that will be helpful to us in future
once AI systems become, you know,
actually dangerous. But it's more likely
that you're just doing engineering to
make a product more marketable and that
is making the world better in a way. But
is that why you got into this? Is that
what you plan to do with your one wild
and precious life? At the end of the
day, your boss is not your friend. The
company is not a family. and it will try
to take your enthusiasm for improving
the world and turn it into enthusiasm
for improving products which is not
quite the same thing. You can of course
go into academia or government or a
nonprofit and in each of those you'll
face a different set of pressures on
your work. What gets you publications
and citations? What gets you funding?
What wins awards? None of these is quite
the same thing as what best solves the
problem. So don't fall prey to good
heart. Keep your eyes on the prize.
Remember that the right thing to do
might look different from what the
people around you are doing. The right
thing to do might not also be the most
prestigious thing or the best
compensated thing. Try to do the right
thing anyway. Some people can remain
master of their fate and captain of
their soul and do good work within an
organizational structure that isn't
designed to support it. You may be one
such person, but it's not the only way
to do things. You may be able to
sidestep the problem by getting
sufficient slack in your life to be a
free agent. In other words, by finding a
source of income which might not be
related to the work you really want to
do, but which leaves you with enough
free time and mental energy to work on
AI safety without getting paid for it.
Taking this path means you're not
beholden to a boss and you can choose to
work on what you think is most
promising. This is valuable because not
every agenda that needs studying is
already being covered. Working outside
of the existing organizations allows you
to find one of those gaps and fill it.
However, this path requires its own type
of mental fortitude without which you
may navigate away from the silla of
conformity right into the caribdess of
crack pottery. Am I being too poetic?
Yes. My point is there's a serious
danger here, which is that without the
structure of a research organization,
you end up doing work that's no good and
worse, never realizing that your work is
no good. You can waste a whole career
this way, but it is avoidable by making
sure to publish often and by frequently
soliciting feedback and peer review and
then actually listening to it, which is
not always psychologically easy. Just
remember that if people don't understand
your ideas, it is almost certainly not
because your ideas are too brilliant.
It's much more likely that you're
communicating poorly and you should
prioritize fixing that. Make sure that
you're contributing to the field in a
way that the field recognizes.
Otherwise, all of your work will have
zero practical effect on the world,
unless you're going to try to build the
AGI on your own, which don't try to
build the AGI on your own,
please. So, if all of that sounds like
not a career you would enjoy, yeah,
maybe it's not for you. There are lots
of ways to help, and technical research
is not the only game in town. This is
important to bear in mind because
success is heavy tailed. By which I
mean, in research, generally, most of
the advances come from relatively few
people. Someone who's amazing at their
job can be many times better than the
average. So, how good it is for you to
do technical safety work ends up mostly
being determined by how likely you are
to be really great at it. This means
that when picking between jobs, even if
technical research feels in some sense
more valuable or important than some
other job you're considering. If you
think you might be really great at that
other job, that might be the better
choice because being excellent at that
other job is better than being a
mediocre researcher. This is tough to
talk about because different people need
to hear different things. If you're
thinking, "Oh, cool. Okay, I can just
work on whatever I'm most excited
about." Then no. The thing you're most
excited about probably doesn't matter
much, you should think about impact
more. But if you're thinking, "Ah, damn.
I got to work on the most important
thing, even if I'm not cut out for it."
Then also, no. If you try that, you're
most likely going to have a miserable
time and burn out and not do much good
for anyone. Frustratingly, the advice
that feels less appealing to you is
probably the advice you most need to
hear. You have to balance these things.
You want to find something that seems
like it might be really important and
useful and that you have a chance of
being great at. But also, you don't have
to decide your whole career in one go.
You can try things and see how it works
out. You can just have a go at getting
into technical AI safety research. You
might find it easier or more fun than
you expected, or you might not. You're
not locked into a single path. You can
always pivot if it's not working out.
People tend to underestimate that. Even
if it turns out technical safety
research isn't for you, you're not going
to say, "Oh, damn. I gained a load of
expertise about this extremely
influential technology for nothing. You
know, you may as well give it a
go. So, what can you do right now? Well,
it'll be different for everyone, but if
you got this far, you should probably
apply for 80,000 hours advising. It's
free. You chat one-on-one with a
professional careers adviser, and
they'll help you think through your next
steps. Of course, they're limited in the
number of people they can talk to,
especially since everyone who watches
this video is going to apply. Yeah, they
might be busy, but it's worth applying
anyway because even just the application
process itself, which only takes about
10 minutes, will help you start thinking
about your career. Link in the
description. Tell them I sent you. Or
don't. Again, not sponsored. Other
careers advice services are available.
In fact, we put together a page at
aafety.com/advisor with several
different organizations you could talk
to. Or without talking to anyone, you
can work through 80,000 hours career
guide. And you can also check out their
job board, which lists open positions
you can apply to. Or you can see courses
that you might want to take at a
safety.com/courses. I think Blue Dot's
AI fundamentals course is particularly
good. And there are too many things in
this call to action. Okay, the main
thing is apply to advising. Okay, just
do that. Yeah, there's not that much
time left. We are not on track. Uh we
need all the help we can get. So, uh
please help. Thanks. Bye.
[Music]
I didn't take any money from 80,000
hours for this video to make sure I
would be free to say whatever I wanted.
So, I want to thank my wonderful patrons
for making that possible. That's all
these amazing people here and in
particular this guy, Maxim. Thank you so
much. I feel so lucky to not have to
take sponsorships. Also, I don't know if
you noticed, but I don't run any YouTube
ads on any of my videos because I think
your time is worth more than that. But I
think YouTube might prefer to promote
videos that have ads since that's how
they make money. So, I'm considering
turning them on just to reach more
people. I don't know. Uh, if I do that,
obviously, you should feel free to use
an ad blocker. But, what do you think?
Uh, I'm obviously especially interested
to hear from patrons, but let me know in
the comments.
[Music]